this is full disclosure who um not
really much full disclosure to us we
know exactly what's happened uh but
Stephen has not like howdy know exactly
what happens and doesn't want to let her
know because she's afraid to either
panic or it'll put her life in more
danger somehow um I think Stephens just
afraid to commit Epico guy yeah you can
tell by when she said so to my face he's
just like twin waterfalls one guys I
need to win waterfalls uh so and that's
pretty much it
um on the one hand it's like you know on
paper I should really like this I kind
of like the stuff like after a big
events are blamed the psychological
stuff sit and sort of like you know
breathe in and take it all in but a lot
of this stuff just may because I've seen
it so much with feels arbitrary
maybe because I've seen you so much in
the I have to protect the loved one so I
cannot tell them it's just been done so
much to death and now it it bored me but
I will see this to this episode's credit
it did this all in one episode how many
times have we seen it with this would
have dragged on for like four or five
episodes before they finally get back
together again what I saw the thing that
was like I don't want to be friends
anymore I rolled my eyes but then I was
also kind of thinking myself they yet
they can't be doing this for a couple
episodes and they don't they wrap it up
which you're right I'm glad they do wrap
it up and there there are some good
stuff I like the edge of that song I
really like incorporating the the
ringtone into the so I like that though
a song that incorporates my cell phone
ringtone that would be like my worst
nightmare as I hell is are you like me
do you hate it when the far I just by
Zilpha know that's why people are always
like why'd you put a more pleasant
sounding rings they don't just hate that
ring now a pleasant sounds that's I
don't want that be like frickin death
metal and I'd be like this is awesome
and then about three days later do it
fuck yeah that's why I could never put
like my favorite song
anything like that as my ringtone I go
insane um but uh and then that you know
it's like the thing with Ronaldo I was
looking at that and you know then
looking out and I'm saying to myself you
know again written that this should
actually be kind of funny cuz he's
clearly not in the same league as him at
all and yet he's acting like you know
he's this huge guy we we must you know
separate ourselves from them we must not
let them be a part of our world and
Stalin saying this should be funny I
just hate him so much
I you beat me to it like I wrote turns
around and leaves and literally the
first words out of his mouth is nope
still hate him and like I looked at it I
was just like you like you beat me by
one second i neuter he was about to say
nope still hate him I hate him even more
because he's one of the reasons that
Steven goes on this whole stupid
escapade of trying to ignore Connie in
this episode I'm sure what he said sunk
in I'm like thanks a lot Ronaldo it's
just like fucking Ronaldo you know what
would have been funny which they started
to do uh is that it would have been
funny Steven he starts to get a little
too sucked in and he's saying stuff that
doesn't even really make sense like you
know no I must have been her we must
build a fence Alpini alligator no no we
need even more than that and I can never
be friends with Connie ever again oh
she's coming up the stairs oh I got hi
guy huh you know it's I kind of like
that like he's getting so deep into it
like he's not I liked his over-reactive
yeah drawing the shades like something
out of fucking epochal yeah like a nose
on it yeah like I needed a mission in
for my sins they gave me one I know I
almost thought they're gonna do a parody
of like all those superhero cliches
where they try to protect the loved one
from knowing the secret behind doing
were almost like it felt like it was
going there I don't know it was an OK
episode I like the fact at least it was
really short but the best thing in it
was amethyst transforming into the
crocodile in that line of just no no you
always want to be the crocodile but you
can never commit which just I'm just
like so this has happened before
multiple times I just just try to wrap
my head around that
that's kind of awesome I just like jay-z
oh you know the one thing I legitimately
question in this that I don't know if
it's like you know a hole or what but
when Pearl says you know it Akane comes
up Stevie's not answering my calls is he
okay yeah you know did anything happen
to him she just goes um I don't really
understand or follow your human ways
your communications - I'm thinking like
okay like we see in the way their
relationships work the gems and stuff
like that they're pretty damn similar to
humans how can they not catch on to some
of this stuff if anyone was going to say
that line and be able to get away with
it don't you think it would be pearl
she's kind of an erotic one that seems a
little off from I mean they're all off
in their own ways but she definitely
seems trapped in her own head Blake yeah
I mean it's I don't know it's one of
those things I know I actually like that
seeing that I love her just look bye no
that wasn't funny
I'm saying that you know by this point I
mean don't you think but keep in mind
that Stephens decision to make hmm not
hers so Stephen doesn't want to be seen
that's you know why me just when she
says I don't really understand your way
but maybe that's part of it may she like
she doesn't know how to respond me well
I tell you how to say no I know I may
not know how to respond or she may even
realize herself it's just a cheap excuse
like I you know it would be like
something on Alf or something obviously
like I uh I don't understand your human
ways later but you know it could be just
you know let's be may end up at alfred's
yeah most amazing sugar Yoda F stands
for alien life-form most Millennials
don't know that hmm do they know what um
we grew up with the show you know do
they know what et stands for um money Oh
Steven Spielberg's career Oh what
Entertainment Tonight
that's true Millennials definitely won
know that hey whatever happened to Leeza
Gibbons
I don't know been John Tesh John Tesh
wrote that amazing MBA that they no tips
the only ending John Tesh every game
something like the FDA theme and
appearing on Conan whenever I watch an
NBA game and I don't hear talentos name
ever and I hate that they don't yeah
that that's so sad
Oh how did we get sidetracked yeah sorry
um but no I'm with you it's an okay
episode um I'm kind of shocked I didn't
buzz it is when he has the episode or
Alf um both said alpha is amazing um I
like cats gold oh you like to eat cancer
how are there cats at melbeck by the way
uh maybe it was like a foreign food they
traveled to earth you may be the Alf
aliens the Mamaki ins abducted cats
that's why I was there to the planet oh
my god okay this episode's okay I'm
kinda shocked I did dislike it as much
as I did cuz it's so charming it's still
even when Steven comes and starts crying
and stuff like that so I think of myself
this is probably why this episode was
made they had this moment where he has
to say something there he has to turn
her away and he can and he's like super
sobbing which is headaches honestly I
think that the scene with his dad was
necessary to where he has the panic
attack in the van I'm like I liked that
a lot cuz like okay he really cares that
he's like having a small panic attack
because of all this shit there were two
jokes s went down there were two jokes I
thought they were gonna do and they
didn't ah one was that when he says I
know where's that soothing music he puts
in your bra bra I thought I was gonna go
oh that's better
III thought bow is gonna be the joke but
again to the story that wouldn't work
and the same thing for this other one I
thought when Steve is looking at the
phone on the cliff and Connie's call you
just as ignore I so want him to just
throw the phone off the cliff and then
go that was stupid I kind of thought he
was gonna pitch the phone yeah I read
that they're doing of that standing on
the cliff like yeah and again just he's
being so sucked into being like the
martyr and stuff like that um so I mean
that's really really nitpicking
um but yeah uh that's about it and we
will see you at the next one we will
return to Alfie logs OH
cats melmac gold
Gordon golden I know we need to stop